[With These Weapons, Copyright MCMXXXIX, American
Social Hygiene Association]
[The Story of Syphilis as told by David Ross]
[Presented by The National Anti-Syphilis Committee
of the American Social Hygiene Association]
[Produced by Willard Pictures]
[Direction & Photography ... Russell S. Bushnell,
Script ... Robert T. Furman, Jr., Assistant
Director ... David H. Lion, Medical Director
... Walter Clarke, M.D., Supervisor ... Edward C. Kienle]
[Music playing; two scientists are seen working
in a lab]
In 1905 the scientist, Fritz Schaudinn, made
one of the most important medical discoveries
of the century. He discovered the spirochaeta
pallida, the germ of syphilis -- syphilis,
the greatest plague of modern times.
The positive identification of the syphilis
germ was the first great step toward the conquest
of this devastating disease. As a mason builds
a house stone-on-stone, so science builds
knowledge on knowledge, bit by bit.
Only a year after the discovery of the syphilis
germ, Bordet and Wassermann developed and
gave the world the first blood test for syphilis.
Syphilis could be diagnosed.
Then, four years later, in 1910, Paul Ehrlich
in his six hundred and six experiments, produced
salvarsan, now called arsphenamine. This drug,
when injected into the body, kills the syphilis
germs.
Ehrlich's brilliant success [inaudible] Bordet
and Wasserman. Syphilis could be cured.
But medical science, never satisfied, marches
on.
Treatment was further improved. In 1922, Levaditi
found that bismuth aids in the cure of syphilis.
Hundreds of other scientists added to medical
knowledge until today the diagnosis and treatment
of syphilis are efficient procedures known
to physicians everywhere.
[ Music ]
[Today syphilis can be cured - or arrested
and made non-infectious.]
In spite of the fact that a cure for syphilis
has been known for 30 years, syphilis today
is one of the most prevalent of serious diseases,
a leading cause of sickness and death.
[Chart reading Estimated Prevalence of Leading Diseases
in the United States, Small Pox 5,371, Infantile
Paralysis 9,511, Typhoid Fever 22,217, Cancer
450,000, Tuberculosis 550,000, Syphilis 6,500,000]
In America, more than six million people have
syphilis, one in 20. There are a million new
cases every year. Why? Certainly its terrible
work can be seen everywhere.
Syphilis strikes infants, kills thousands.
When it does not kill, it may cause blindness,
deafness, insanity, or deformity.
In adults, syphilis is a leading cause of
heart disease. It strikes men and women in
the prime of life, makes many helpless invalids.
Its victims help fill the ever-expanding institutions
for the insane.
It breaks up homes, causes many divorces.
Wars, syphilis kills more than wars.
Fires, syphilis costs more than fires, floods, or
famine. Why, why when physicians everywhere
can diagnose and treat syphilis, do we permit
this pale, spiral germ to continue its devastation?
The answer is ignorance. Ignorance is the
greatest ally of syphilis.
The rich are penalized by lack of knowledge
as well as the poor. Both suffer because they
have not learned the simple, hopeful truth
about syphilis, that it can be cured and its
spread can be prevented.
Fortunately times are changing. Newspapers
are aiding the campaign against ignorance.
The radio is presenting the facts to millions.
Literature is being distributed and read.
Speakers are instructing thousands so that
they will be able to protect themselves and
others from syphilis.
[A wide-spread knowledge of the facts of syphilis
is the nation's hope of wiping out this insidious disease.]
Anyone who thinks he has syphilis should go
at once to a physician because only a physician
can diagnose syphilis. Early symptoms are
sometimes so slight that they may pass unnoticed.
The disease develops insidiously. Years sometimes
elapse before it makes itself known. A knowledge
of the patient's history is the first step
in diagnosis. Then follows a thorough physical examination.
If sores are found, as is often the case in
early syphilis, a dark field microscope is
used to determine whether or not [...?]. An
essential part of any examination for syphilis
is a blood test.
The doctor takes a sample of the patient's
blood, seals it in a sterile tube and sends
it to a laboratory. There the delicate and
complicated test is applied. The results are
checked and then recorded on individual cards.
Only a physician can interpret the results
of the test. When syphilis is found, treatment
must begin at once. Early treatment is a patient's
great hope of recovery.
Cases discovered in the early stages can usually
be made noninfectious and completely cured.
Even in neglected cases, the disease can often
be arrested and suffering relieved.
Modern treatment usually consists of injections
of some form of arsphenamine and bismuth which
can be taken without interfering with a patient's
daily work.
Treatment must be taken regularly and persistently.
Injections over a period of a year or longer
may be required for permanent results.
The patient must also follow the doctor's
orders as to food, proper rest, and particularly
his precautions for protecting the health
of others.
For syphilis is a catching disease, especially
in its early stage. Transmitted nearly always
by close body contact, it spreads from man
to woman, from woman to man, from husband
to wife and often from mother to unborn child
as it claims its million victims a year.
Since any syphilis infection is always linked
to one or more others, doctor and patient
must cooperate to bring under medical care
the person who is spreading infection, for
treatment makes syphilis noninfectious.
The treatment of a single case may prevent
the suffering, disability, and perhaps the
death of no one knows how many others.
[ Music ]
[Syphilis can be conquered. Physicians, nurses,
health officers, and citizens working together
can bring syphilis under control in one generation.]
With the medical profession as the spearhead
of the attack, the fight against syphilis
is well begun. Physicians are more alert than
ever to discover and treat infections in all
persons under their care.
Free clinics, hospitals, and health departments
provide medical care for those who can afford
to pay only small fees or nothing at all.
Health agencies contribute by helping to trace
infections and by teaching syphilis victims
how to prevent the spread of infections.
Many states now require that every expectant
mother be examined and her blood tested for
syphilis, a most important step, for it is
one of the miracles of medicine that modern
treatment prevents the transmission of syphilis
from mother to unborn child.
An increasing number of states require that
before marriage both bride and groom have
an examination, including a blood test for
syphilis, and similar laws are being pushed
in other states, for government has found
that millions now spent for the support of
institutions for victims of syphilis can be
saved.
Industry too is beginning to realize that
war against syphilis is tremendously important.
Compensation costs, costly accidents, and
labor turnover often chargeable to syphilis
can be reduced, and so many industries are
encouraging infected employees to secure treatment.
But the work has only begun. There is much
to do. Government and citizens have a tremendous
task ahead. Schools have a responsibility
to teach youth the ways of health. For 75
percent of all syphilis is contracted before
the age of 30.
Churches can do much by instilling high ideals.
Parents can guide, protect, and instruct growing
children. Communities can provide facilities
for wholesome play.
And communities too must enforce laws which
protect you from degrading conditions.
Yes, there is much to be done, but thanks
to medical science, thanks to research workers,
physicians, and public health leaders, all
of the weapons for a successful war against
syphilis are at hand.
Syphilis can be diagnosed. It can be made
noninfectious. It can be cured. Only one more
thing is needed to defeat the germs of syphilis:
knowledge of the facts by every man and woman.
With widespread knowledge and with these weapons,
America can conquer syphilis in one generation.
[The End]